ich persönlich bin sogar so verzweifelt
ich gehe ab dem 30 august in den
unbefristeten hungerstreik weil ich kein
anderes mittel mehr seher und meiner
stimme gehör zu verschaffen
viele leute sagen dass die sollte nicht
sterben
[Musik]
mir steckt bereits in der klimakrise
city arizona das jetzt business basiere
und es gibt dort sachlicher verhandelt
wo das klima ist immer mehr macht wir
stehen an einer wegkreuzung ausland oder
aussterben immer mehr menschen setzen
sich aktiv für umweltschutz
die eine völlig kreativ
andere versuchen mit gezielten aktionen
auf klimapolitik aufmerksam zu machen
und es braucht die wüste geht sogar so
weit dass im kampf fürs klima wird
sterben wenn ich glaube aber wir tun
etwas ich habe gewonnen
vier monate lang auch nicht verschiedene
kollektiv und rebellion bewilligte und
illegale protestaktionen begleitet
ich wollte wissen wie fit und
klimaaktivisten fürs klima
[Musik]
später zwei und drei der gruppe
klimaaktivisten aktion plant hand
klimabewegung rise of the change
marschiert richtung bundesplatz gruppe
plant forum regierungsgebäude ist
unbewilligte theater eine von der aktion
ist stefanie sie fühlt sich vor der
klimakrise bedroht wenn geschlemmt sich
lisa demmer des auges leistung hat baden
im las er wusste schlimm ist und
dann beißt er habe mehrfach aktiv zu
oder nicht stimmt so hat er mitglied
überzahl als motivieren und das heißt so
nach kraft dieser und schon war das
einzige
schiff setzen mögen warum darüber reden
aber die
zwei
jahren hague sprach gesucht kam zeit
direkt ja dass meine schrift würde es
ist nicht so dass mir macht es ist
wirklich
beachtet
das war nahmen die krise wartet immer
belagert neu ist dass auch hersteller
ist gezaubert stefanie erzählt mir sie
möchten mit dem theater aufmerksam
machen dass banken mit os egal welche
unternehmen investiert
[Applaus]
apa
so hetzt ein klein vom bundeshaus zu der
aufstellt und tat um das sind die partei
beschütze und aktivisten versuche die
aktie unter den tab oder stier
aktion nicht so war sehr kreativ das
intro medien und die spiele durch
eigentliche schlüsselrolle wieso
aktionen vor allem wenn es keine
zuschauer hat nun frage ich mich bei hat
ihre botschaft überhaupt mit beruf
später geht's dann wieder im programm
mit dem bewilligte teil jetzt sind so
viel medi womit machen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
stimmige stürzte ernsthaft ohligs klasse
fröhlich doch dann wird so warm und
ernst
stehen an einer rekord zum aufstand oder
aussterben ich persönlich bin sogar so
verzweifelt ich gehe ab dem 30 august in
den unbefristeten hungerstreik weil ich
kein anderes mittel mehr seher und
meiner stimme gehör zu verschaffen
was die bühne seid überrasch mich und
ich möchte mir vor
die möglichkeit als unserer stimme gehör
zu verschaffen und presse donnerstag
nochmals ich mit meinem lebensstil
was ist was ist da eine grenze im
optimismus meine ganze
jetzt erst mal nicht zu sterben dabei
also erstmal weiter zu machen aber wenn
es so weitergeht
man braucht auch mehr zu
gebrauchen ist es nicht gefällt den
körper
aus abnahme ungewöhnliche sorgen muss
was erwartet mich nicht mehr zusteht so
jürgen versorgt dankeschön
[Applaus]
er will für fendrich der klimakrise
sogar sterbe und gott jetzt am 30 august
hungerstreik
sterbe fürs klima das hat mich ab dem
zeitpunkt auf eine beschäftigung komme
auch den punkt wo man ernsthaft darüber
nachdenkt sich irgendwann dafür zu
opfern natur liegt doch in ihren herzen
und ich fahre immer mit stil sind
erfolge aber in einen hungerstreik ska
oder sogar fürs klima sterbe ich mir
vorstelle also jetzt einen monat nach
der klimademonstration in bayern ich
kann den bayern mit dem ruhm und geld er
hat seinen hungerstreik fürs klima die
kontrollbeteiligung mit dem schreiben er
ist jetzt am tag acht und haben folglich
machen telefonieren
waren auch da waren wie gesagt auf den
zivilen widerstand geleistet und gesetze
überschritten war im gefängnis habe ich
auch an der fall und
das hat alles nicht aufgehört wir haben
versucht druck zu machen wir werden
nicht
gehen wir einen hungerstreik die ferien
zu zeigen man ist wirklich ernst wir
könnten auch militant werden und hier
durch die gegend streifen und uns
bewaffnen aber das tun wir nicht
wegschauen wenn sonst friedlichen
widerstand leisten und wenn man mal mit
offenen augen durch die welt schaut dann
ist genau das was ich tue an den
hungerstreik zu gehen vollkommen der
situation angemessen und erfolg haben in
der realität blumen erzählt mir dass er
alles auf der aktivismus setzt er hat
seine wohnung oft sind die becken leer
abbruch und wohnt momentan mit der
andere sachsen steigender im klima camp
vor dem reichstagsgebäude in berlin die
vorträge des öffentliches gespräch mit
den drei kanzlerkandidaten zum thema
mord an der jungen gesellschaft wie ist
die aufmerksamkeit auf eure aktion
wir werden sonst einfach eskalieren die
ja keine ahnung machen weglassen dann
wird es schlechter geht und gegangen ich
verfolge der hungerstreik von human und
seine mitstreiterinnen wie durch social
media da ich viel angst und verzweiflung
viel negatives bei uns im gegensatz zu
dem was ich zugleich ist sie da in
zürich am internationalen klima streng
das
[Musik]
mittelmeer das bisschen
selbstdarstellung
effektiver also effektive anschließen
ich bin es geht einfach nur für
wacker chemie auf dem sofa und
ms office und
jugendarzt
einkaufen oder die zukunft netzteil wird
nun tatsächlich noch als ultra frage ist
nur ein ganz passabler aber es ist nicht
unmöglich
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also andere stimmung steigt unser trikot
musikspiele der hand haben was hab ich
genieße die sonne die lockere stelle
erwähnt
[Musik]
es geht es nötig in den hungerstreik das
klima findet das nachvollziehen
mit einer wirklich statement das ist
gesetzt schaltet ja wusste den apple
sony würde
ist klar ich würde
mir fällt auf dass dort zu die
vorwiegend junge frauen mit laufen und
sich so fürs klima engagiert im
hungerstreik berlin sind sie in gemona
und ich freue mich dass man
grundsätzlich wieder im aktivismus
da von der polizei begleitet
[Applaus]
so wie weit die
machtelite
straßendecke
30 in
den beruf
[Applaus]
positiver wandel und zeige zum maße
mobilisiere ganz andere strategie vor
der hungerstreikende zu berlin die
erzählt uwe schuss um danke für politik
und gesellschaft zum wohl von klima
auf der foto nichts wie ab kraft aber
wie entschlossen gruppe für ihre gestört
es ist jetzt rund zwei wochen
wurden abkommen hat mit seinen kollegen
der hungerstreik machen berlin ich habe
mit ihm telefoniert kirk seit wenn sich
nicht alle dann verzichte ziehung
verdünnte frucht saft das ist einziger
rosine konsumiert hat über instagram
habe ich dann gesehen dass eine vor der
hungerstreikenden um auch kritisch mit
ihm zu 100 medien jetzt aufwand darüber
zu berichten und ich bin auf der citrix
hat die kriegsstraße und bauxit
meldungen wie seine kollegen im
hungerstreik boni wieder recherchiert
haben
vor 18 stunden ist ein klima aktivist
macht ich wurde und die später nicht
liefert wenige tag später um die zweit
klimaaktivisten spital wo jetzt da wird
europa wird vom berliner klima camp und
im hungerstreik berichtet vereinzelt
könnte manchen solidarische hungerstreik
die große mobilisierung blieb tabus
und auch ins ziel nämlich mit dem
kanzlerkandidaten trainer hans mühl
gereicht es ist hier 20 und lautstark
von hungerstreiks
kanzlerkandidaten bereits mit dem roman
und co und das auch beendet sie jetzt
allerdings handelt zwei finger hand sein
dass sie wieder gönnt ihnen doch hallo
ich bin henning ich habe jetzt seit 27
tagen nichts gegessen und
ich werde halt schon noch anfangen
nichts mehr zu trinken und das ganze aus
dem grund dass in diesem wahlkampf in
dem es um alles geht
nach wie vor so getan wird als könnte es
irgendwie alles weitergehen und gerade
von den kandidatinnen die gerade beliebt
sind von herrn scholz beispielsweise
nicht einmal im über die lippe kommt
klima notstand zu sagen der trockene
hungerstreik führt dazu dass in
deutschland über das klima und
aktivismus diskutiert wird und autor der
schweizer wird auch die vision und
aktivisten
gruppe extinction rebellen hat große
kündet innovations- woche zur ilanz
lecker bekannt wurde ist gruppe durch
aktionen mit kunstblut in bern oder der
grünen-experte lima zürich
mit tanz mit mir sieht steigt er störe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist ein bunter mix aus auto und
jungen frauen und männer sind wieder als
derjenige lutz bernhardt welle mit
zarter auf die klima notstand aufmerksam
machen die bienen kaufs gesetz sprache
und dafür von der polizei festgesetzt
werden und
dank
und fangt diejenigen kräfte gut straßen
nicht freiwillig verlängert
nein das nicht absolut lehrbuchmäßig die
machen ihren job wirklich gut und die
jetzt noch drin sind wir
sind drin bleiben sie das anwenden wenn
sie zeit an hey es ist mal richtig nur
gefahren ich rechne ganz die voll
stunden sind wichtige verkehrsstraße die
innenstadt von zürich nach der
störaktion blockiert aber zeigt das
ganze die gewünschte wirkung woche nach
der protestbrief ich mich noch mal mit
dem markus er ist friede mit aktion
suche media hackett übertrieben
berichtet und somit auch über ihre
vorträge außerdem hat sich follower
zahlen auf ihren social media kanal
verdoppelt bedeutet das dass auch die
vision ihren aktionen immer extremer
werden gab das wetter falls zurück oder
junge 24 cent dass er sich das klima
ich befürchte das land sich nicht für
meter vielleicht ist wird es noch nicht
in den nächsten paar jahre auf der fall
sie aber ich weiß nicht was ich denen
sie wo
china tibet
immer wieder mal
markus flik für sich keine zukunft mehr
gesehen und gesagt okay 11 nachher mache
dass ich
mich so krass wie druckluft
und nachvollziehbar dass das dass ich
irgendwas kann autos mit dem wir haben
nämlich lebens zu befürchten steht dass
sie dafür 20 uhr steht dann hat das für
energieforschung nach
ich bin vor sind die hohen streicher des
berliner zur wiege noch sieben stunden
ohne trinke herrn situation abbruch
henning hat die folgende drei tage auf
der intensivstation verbracht und spürte
mach mit ines interview per video call
was hat der hungerstreik und in deinem
fall auch der durch streiks
schlussendlich gebracht wir haben die
ignoranz gebrochen die vorher von
politischer seite so viele menschen in
verzweiflung gebracht hat nachdem alle
gesagt haben ja mit dem hungerstreik da
werden werde die ignoriert werden das
ist ja wirklich nur zu belächeln jetzt
ist aber in fünf tagen ein gespräch in
dem wir mit dem wohl nächsten
bundeskanzler deutschlands olaf scholz
live öffentlich übertragen eben reden
werden und das ganze kann nur der beginn
sein die junge generation die schaut
genau auf das was jetzt kommt und wir
sehen auch wenn die maßnahmen eben nicht
ausreichen dann müssen wir nach dem
gespräch auch in aktion weiter treten
ich glaube aber es ist gar nicht an mir
jetzt ich werde niemanden zum
hungerstreik einladen oder vorbereiten
es ist das jetzt also der beginn und wir
sehen es geht weiter und das bedeutete
auch für mich ich war nach dem hunger
nach dem durch streik körperlich
wirklich an einem punkt an dem es
riskanter wurde und ich war aber bewusst
da hingegangen weil ich einfach sehe was
auf dem spiel steht und wir sehen ja
auch gerade jetzt ist in der schweiz
wieder ein mensch in den hungerstreik
gegangen wer wirklich sagt
ich mein leben aufs spiel setzen
ich bin auf dem bahnhof bern sieht nun
tragischen dreifacher familienvater
wusste westschweiz im hungerstreik auf
dem bundesplatz
was trieb die notizen vorige und wie wie
twitter tatsächlich gab
ich drifte it-spezialist guillermo nach
seiner pause am nachmittag übernachtet
wird drinnen im hotel in anarchie der
größte davon tag verbringt er aber auf
dem stuhl da verteilt flyer und redet
mit menschen über kinder ja ich denke
der tränke brauen dass sie für die
kinder mehr schaden hinterlassen wenn
sie muss gepflegt werden
aus wenn sie anderweitig werden mit der
profession diese habe als
computerspezialist haben
weit gefehlt
ich denke ich danke wirklich und henkel
nicht hey
hey mann und glaubst du das was du jetzt
macht ein teil der lösung ist viele
leute sagen dass ich sollte nicht
sterben ich bin eine gute person ich
habe kinder und so weiter und ich
verstehe das wirklich aber die streiks
kleinklima ein tag in einer woche das
ist das ja nie genug sein dann wirklich
streik würde
es starts und das ändert nichts wissen
das ist gewonnen die wahrheit ist nicht
zu sterben in einen kampf jetzt
hier wir denken dass es ist möglich
einen kampf zu geworden zu gewinnen ohne
risiko das ist nicht wahr und das ist
mir wirklich ein anliegen ich möchte
dich oder habe ich auch schon henning
hab ich habe schon gesagt ich möchte
euch mit dieser die präsenz nicht
motivieren irgendwie weiter zu weit zu
gehen ich habe größten respekt vor eurem
commitment zum thema
ich finde es aber auch extrem krass in
beschriebe auch simonetta sommaruga
forderte das sieht bundesversammlung
über der aktuelle klima notstand
informiert das was du machst
wahrscheinlich ja
wenn ich sterbe aber sind zu nett was
ich habe gewonnen aber nicht aber sie
tun nichts
ich habe verloren aber für meine kinder
sie würden für immer ein beispiel haben
so viele kinder wie vodafone corsa war
wird trocken
nora petra jenner glück war
das heute eine unglaubliche szene du
hast den kinder gesagt was das was du
machst und die kinder haben gequatscht
weil sie wissen dass es ist die wissens
ist für sie und sie wissen schon dass
die klima
wird gleich sein für sich und sie sehen
einer wagt ein erwachsener
das stück etwas
das ist denn den job von den eltern
nicht die kinder die kinder sollte nicht
kämpfen für ihre zukunft zu erweitern
das ist für mich nicht nur mal das ist
als ob ich immer wieder gehört es ist
gar nicht möglich an einem hungerstreik
in der öffentlichkeit zu sterben weil du
irgendwann ohnmächtig werden
zwangsernährt werden würdest das ist
verboten ist es verboten ich weiß dass
irgendwann sich auch das ist gegen die
menschlichkeit
menschenrechte auszusteigen etwas
schriftliches hinterlassen dass falls
die ärzte dich
dass aber der stabil auf mir das hast du
immer auf die
dass sie nötig weil
das trug kommt aus
das sterben
das ist schrecklich ich weiß aber es ist
so wahr wenn sie wissen sie sie können
warten sie warten möchtest du
dass leute ein beispiel nehmen an dir
und auch in dem solidarische hunger
start gehen ich hoffe ich bin wirklich
ich hoffe ich tue es so dass niemand
anders hast das zu tun
im schlimmsten fall bis zu
50 60 tage hier und das ist dann das im
winter
und
weihnachten hier
also schon gedacht es könnte sein dass
die um weihnachten das würde so schön
wirklich dass er eine frauengeschichte
noch nicht
aber
ich bin ein mensch
[Gelächter]
sprich mit dem gehen manchmal grad
extrem gegangen er startet seiner
lebensfreude und das obwohl momentan
gerade im hungerstreik
was machst du umso tragischer dass so
wie gott oder sowie moskau wien es wird
ca und ja das macht mir ich sehe mich
zwar selber nur das klima aktivisten
jetzt nicht mit dem transparent durch
straße ziehen oder mit dem sitzstreik
den verkehr blockieren aber ich möchte
selber aktiv sie und volk mich ernsthaft
ob ich mich und die machen für das klima
war mir wirklich am herzen liegt muss
ich vielleicht aufhören mit dem flugzeug
ab suchen aber was haltet ihr vom ganzen
welt die maßnahme findet er gönnt suite
wäre es in legitim sie was mir durch der
uni kommentar um eine zum thema zivile
ungehorsam und wisse als auf impact hat
das video dazu gemacht moni wärmstens
empfehlen